facts Britain's housing mortgage markets
in meltdown and estate agent jaspal
signi fears for his business the
government's plan for sweeping tax cuts
and huge amounts of borrowing spooked
investors forcing dozens of lenders to
pull hundreds of mortgage deals buyers
are understandably quite anxious about
what's going to happen next um I think
the key thing we've got to remember is
buyers are also sellers we're seeing the
lower level of buyers coming to the
markets we're at a 40 reduction in
buyers actually registering who've got
mortgages approved in principle and this
is even I think this trend is going to
continue just with with obviously
suspension on certain mortgage products
while buyers and sellers re-evaluate
their options the international monetary
fund the lender of Last Resort
urged the British government to
reconsider cutting taxes at a time of
soaring inflation the IMF fears it will
spark a global slowdown and risks
widening inequality the kind of warning
the IMF gives to emerging economies not
the UK
last Friday the chancellor of the
exchequer announced a bonanza of tax
cuts and debt-funded spending in the
hopes of stimulating economic growth
but the move has spectacularly backfired
the value of the pound plummeting to its
lowest level since 1985. the whole
Market is in turmoil at the moment and
people are waiting for some uh
conciliatory tones from having the
chancellor or the bank of England to
actually settle the markets down and at
the moment that hasn't been forthcoming
the figures forced the bank of England
on Wednesday to take evasive action and
buy government bonds on a temporary
basis to help calm the market but within
minutes the pound fell again down 1.6
percent against the dollar
as the pound Falls the cost of
government borrowing on the
international bond markets has gone up
from an interest rate of around one and
a half to two and a half percent to five
percent seemingly overnight expressing a
real lack of Confidence from investors
about the government's ability to pay
for its own plans UK debt is now seen by
investors as being similar to Greece or
Italy countries with long histories of
economic mismanagement even before all
this inflation the gradual increase in
the price of goods over a year was
around 10 percent its highest in 40
years and the highest amongst G7
advanced economies a perfect storm of
factors including the war in Ukraine
have disrupted supplies of goods such as
oil wheat and fertilizer pushing up the
price of food Fuel and other items and
in order to dampen those Rises the bank
of England that acts independently of
the government has raised interest rates
the cost of borrowing to slow down
spending and keep prices under control
but the turbulent pound means only one
thing the bank of England responding
with even higher rates of interest to
help steady prices
the heads of some of the world's leading
Banks were summoned to the treasury to
try to restore confidence in the
government's plans but politically
things are anything but stable there's
disquiet amongst MPS from the governing
conservative party some reportedly
calling for Liz truss's Premiership to
end before it's really begun Neeve
Barker Al Jazeera London